you've invented Bayesian networks that
look awfully a lot like they express
something like causation but they don't
not necessarily so how do we turn
Bayesian networks into expressing
causation how do we build causal
networks this a causes B because a see
how do we start to infer that kind of
thing we start asking ourself question
what are the factors that would
determine the value of x X could be
blood pressure death hungry anger but
these are hypotheses that we provide cuz
this is everything which has to do with
causality comes from a theory
differences only what kind of how you
interrogate the theory give in your mind
so it still needs the human expert to
propose all right you need the human
expert to specify the initial model
initial model could be very qualitative
just who listens to whom by whom listen
to I mean one variable listen to the
other
okay the tide is listening to the moon
and not to the rooster crow and so forth
this is our understanding of the world
in which we live
scientific understanding of reality we
have to stop there because if we don't
know how to handle cause-and-effect
relationship when we do have a model and
we certainly do not know how to end it
when we don't have a model so let's
start first in AI slogan is
representation first discovery second if
I give you all the information that you
need can you do anything useful with it
that is the first representation how do
you represent it I give you all the
knowledge in the world how do you
represent it
when you presented I asked you can you
infer X or Y or Z can you answer certain
queries is it a complex is it polynomial
it called the computer science exercises
we do once you give me a representation
for my knowledge then you can ask me now
I'd understand how to represent things
how do I discover them it's a secondary
thing the result we should I call the
statement that mathematics and the
current much of the machine learning
world has not considered causation that
a causes B just in anything so that that
seems like us that seems like a non
obvious thing that you you think we
would have really acknowledged it but we
have it so we have to put that on the
table Oh
knowledge how hard is it to create a
knowledge from which to work in certain
area it's easy because we have only four
or five major variables in an
epidemiologist so an economist can put
them down what minimum wage unemployment
policy XYZ and stop collecting data and
quantify the parameter that were left
unquantified with the initial knowledge
that's the routine work that you find in
Experimental Psychology yes in economics
everywhere any in the health science
it's a routine things but I should
emphasize you should start with the
research question what do you want to
estimate once you have that you have a
language of expressing what you want to
estimate you think it's easy no
you